it may be July but the ski slopes are
still packed in California lifts ran on
Independence Day at the [ __ ] Valley ski
area for the fourth time in history as
the winters record-breaking snow melts
at is creating raging rivers downstream
dozens of people have been rescued from
the Truckee River Carter Evans followed
the water from the peaks of [ __ ] Valley
to the desert floor below in the High
Sierra of California it's continuing to
look a lot like Christmas but in July
two weeks after the official start of
summer skiers at [ __ ] Valley are
refusing to let temperatures near 80
degrees melt away their favorite winter
sport what's the difference between a
winter skier and a spring summer skier
they're basically the same they're just
wearing less [ __ ] Valley president and
CEO Andy Wirth
thanks last winter's epic snowfall for
his ability to keep the chairs lifting
into July we have this concept we're
gonna run it as the 2016 17 18 season
we're gonna take two ski seasons put
them together
this is absolutely uncharted territory
but while these folks are rushing
downhill federal snowpack monitor Jeff
Henderson is heading up to check on a
data collection site nestled between
runs it basically is a big scale that
measures how much weight there is in the
snowpack
although this one's empty a few
mountains over how much snow is here now
there's about four of little over four
feet right now we're standing on this
station is still buried in winter we had
two and a half times as 250% means two
and a half winners of snow we got this
one winner
as it melts most of the snow in these
mountains flows downhill to the same
destination the 191 square mile catch
basin known as Lake Tahoe we have seen
more inflow to the lake this year than
any years since we have records back to
1900 US District Court water master Chad
Blanchard keeps an eye on water levels
at the lake in just one week during
California's recent heatwave more than
12 billion gallons of water poured in
it's now only two inches from being full
there are 63 identified streams that
feed Lake Tahoe and how many routes out
one route out that's the Truckee River
right because of this year's sheer
volume Blanchard has had to release ten
times more water through this dam than
in a normal year that's causing serious
trouble downstream search and rescue
teams down in Reno Nevada are training
for their worst they've rescued more
than 20 people from the raging current
so far this year and at least three have
been swept to their death it's flowing
about at least double of what we would
normally expect this time of year mark
bell of the Washoe County hasty team
says recreational swimmers and kayakers
are being caught off guard by a river
that's usually far more placid they'll
decide to just maybe get in the river
just a little bit and then the river
basically takes them off their feet
it's happening all over the West the
California Highway Patrol recently
plucked this man from a rock in the
middle of the nearby nuba River he was
just a few feet away from plunging over
a 50-foot waterfall thority say training
exercises like these are essential
because while the water is raging down
in Reno there's plenty more where that
came from back up here most
climatologist will tell you that this is
a function of volatility of weather
patterns and we will see more like this
going forward so we have ups and downs
we are for CBS this morning Carter Evans
Lake Tahoe we saw Carter skiing and the
team so clearly he knows exactly what
he's doing on he was involved but I'm
telling you I was just in Wyoming but
either the water you step in it moves
much faster than you think all of a
sudden for a state that badly needed the
water it's pretty impressive the fact
that they you know they're getting the
water but so dangerous yet you know
those currents can just work me right
out but the skiers are saying we get to
ski yeah anyway in July when you're
wearing it that's not so bad if you're
good on those slopes